[Música]
el viernes 22 de julio se firman turquía
un acuerdo entre kiev y moscú y la onu
que permite la exportación de granos
represados desde la invasión rusa
ucrania un acuerdo frágil plagado
también de escepticismo interrogantes y
es que pudiera deshacerse en cualquier
momento esto debido a los temores de
ucrania y que rusia pudiera atacar desde
el mar a cualquiera de sus puertos algo
que ya ocurrió pasó el sábado un día
después de la firma de este acuerdo
cuando rusia atacó con misiles a
objetivos en el puerto de odessa
salgamos entonces a nuestro primer
invitado del día ls blame y rubinsky
profesor de ciencia política y
relaciones internacionales de la
universidad icesi gracias a vladimir por
estar con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 por supuesto también nos
acompaña en esta mesa de trabajo en este
periodista de economía daniel hablando
andan y bienvenida muchas gracias raúl
buenos días y pues muy interesante ese
tema porque recordemos que ucrania y
rusia son dos de las despensas grandes
despensas mundiales de alimentos y tiene
toda la palabra daniela para empezar
esta conversación con vladímir rubinsky
bueno señor vladimir muy buenos días y
comienzo por
preguntarle pues en qué consiste
específicamente este acuerdo y qué
mensaje trata de dar rusia pues atacando
uno de los puertos de ucrania un día
después de firmar el acuerdo
muy buenos días muchas gracias por la
invitación yo creo que el acuerdo entre
rusia y ucrania
de hecho respaldado por las naciones
unidas y turquía en busca de varios
objetivos en primer lugar se trata de un
intento de rusia de mostrar que es un
actor legítimo en la arena internacional
una diputación que fue obviamente
bastante cuestionada por romper varios
acuerdos internacionales por el hecho de
comenzar la guerra en ucrania por otro
lado el acuerdo también busca facilitar
más allá del envío de trigo algunos
otros elementos facilitar para rusia
misma el envío de algunos de los
productos que ahora están bajo del
régimen de las sanciones o que tienen
dificultades para ser transportados por
ejemplo lo que importa américa latina
son los fertilizantes y yo creo que lo
que ocurrió en odessa es un mensaje de
hecho de rusia
si bien bruce está interesado en cumplir
con
algunos por lo menos de los
términos de este acuerdo sin embargo
rusia está destinado también y tiene
como su prioridad la continuación de la
guerra en ucrania claro entonces
teniendo en cuenta todo este panorama
wlademir él le pregunto si ucrania puede
decir entonces pues ya no sigo con este
acuerdo porque usted me está atacando
era uno de los miedos y digamos una de
las trabas que tenía ucrania para firmar
este acuerdo que incluso recordemos que
dijo que no lo estaba firmando con rusia
sino que le estaba firmando con la onu
en pro digamos de liberar todos estos
granos para que no se produzca más se
agudicen mejor dicho esta crisis
alimentaria sobre todo en asia y áfrica
realmente ucrania puede decir ya no de
más con este acuerdo
yo creo que todavía no porque
básicamente hay también hay una presión
sobre ucrania
igualmente para poder
continuar con algunos de los compromisos
asumidos pero yo creo que también hay
una jugada compleja por parte del
gobierno ruso que busca por un lado
adelantar y tratar de avanzar el derecho
con su estrategia no carne pero en el
mismo tiempo en buscar las oportunidades
de presionar a otros actores en la arena
internacional como por ejemplo los
países de áfrica a donde fue muy
recientemente el ministro de relaciones
exteriores ruso serguéi lávrov y en
áfrica 40% de trigo por ejemplo proviene
de rusia ucrania entonces ahí hay una
jugada muy compleja en que ucrania
lamentablemente para los ucranianos
realmente está en una posición bastante
débil señor vladimir si lleváramos el
tema o lo trajéramos mejor américa
latina parece que hay oportunidades
porque por un lado si se si ese acuerdo
pues tiene efectos podríamos estar
hablando de que se nos van a destrabar
las exportaciones desde rusia de
fertilizantes como usted lo decía que de
las cuales somos muy dependientes pero
por otro lado si no llegara a suceder
pues también tenemos una oportunidad
para los países de nosotros que también
producen granos como lo son argentina o
brasil
usted cómo ve todo este panorama para
américa latina como nos va a beneficiar
o no este acuerdo
bueno nosotros podemos tener como una
referencia reciente a la crisis de 2014
cuando rusia inició su avance hacia el
territorio ucraniano cuando fue anexada
la península de crimea y cuando fueron
aplicadas por primera vez las sanciones
del occidente sobre ruso en ese entonces
también se hablaron sobre las
oportunidades para américa latina y sin
embargo en una buena parte de los casos
no se logró avanzar demasiado en este
aspecto y la razón detrás de estas
dificultades es precisamente quien no es
simplemente el hecho de ser productor de
ciertos mercancías sino que también la
existencia de las cadenas globales de
valor entonces donde están involucradas
también tales temas como el transporte
en todo el tema de la logística y yo
creo para américa latina para poder
aprovechar esta una nueva oportunidad
que si estoy de acuerdo es una
oportunidad pero que tiene que hacer un
esfuerzo bastante
fuerte para poder tomar el provecho de
esta situación ya emir también le quiero
preguntar digamos económicamente cuánto
se estaría desbloqueando no en todas
estas importaciones sobre todo cuánto
dinero le pudiera entrar a ucrania si
también turquía y perdón rusia se
beneficiaría de este bloqueo de los
puertos y esta exportación de los granos
bueno allá estamos hablando de un
escenario bastante
multidimensional porque una parte del
trigo por ejemplo ucraniano ahora esta
base cambiante robado por parte de
rousseff porque está en las manos de los
rusos que cuando ocuparon el territorio
de ucrania ellos también realmente están
la posición ahora de algunos de los
productos y alguna mercancía que de
origen es de ucrania y la cantidad de
dinero que puede entrar a rusia o puede
entrar otra es significativo pero en el
caso de rusia es mucho menor que los
ingresos que ellos tienen por la venta
de petróleo y gas señor vladimir yo
quisiera que habláramos de los precios
desde que inició la guerra los precios
del trigo se han disparado hoy hoy
particularmente han subido un 4 por
ciento después de este ataque no de esa
y después de haber perdido un 6% cuando
se anunció el acuerdo cómo ha sido ese
aumento de precios y cómo afecta eso
también a nivel mundial porque a veces
pensamos que porque estamos tan lejos de
ucrania en américa latina' me refiero
pues no nos va a afectar ese aumento de
precios pero para que nos explique un
poquito cómo funciona todo este tema de
los precios
bueno nosotros estamos viviendo en una
economía globalizada
y esto obviamente el tema de de la
agricultura o el tema de los productos
agrarios no es una excepción
los precios aumentan porque hay un temor
que no va a haber cierto producto en
este caso que hay un tct de los
productos asociados con rusia y ucrania
o donde rusia ucrania son algunos o unos
de los proveedores centrales y si bien
nosotros yo creo que aquí en américa
latina como tal somos productores de una
buena parte de lo que produce también
rusia ucrania por la demanda en los
mercados internacionales puede ver que
algunos de los proveedores pueden
decidir vender estos productos en otros
mercados donde la oferta es mucho más
alta pues de vladimir muchísimas gracias
por su tiempo por analizar un poco este
acuerdo frágil digamos esta pausa la
guerra precisamente en los puertos para
poder exportar todos estos granos pero
pues usted también se está aprovechando
para atacar como bien lo dijo esos
objetivos militares que no va a cesar
hacia un acuerdo para la exportación
daño así es y yo creo que debemos
pararle muchas bolas amena al tema de
los fertilizantes que nos pues nos ha
pegado tanto en américa latina que somos
muy dependientes de los fertilizantes
rusos